no entres en pánico prepárate ese es el
lema con el que grupos militares
entrenan a voluntarios y veteranos
ucranianos dispuestos a defender el país
ante una posible invasión rusa
no se supone que todo el mundo sepa
disparar correr ser un profesional pero
por desgracia en la realidad actual esto
es lo que nos dictan las circunstancias
saber al menos un nivel elemental de
cómo comportarse durante un bombardeo
o le pertenece al batallón de azov un
grupo de voluntarios de extrema derecha
que en su momento luchó contra los
separatistas de danny es que actualmente
el destacamento se encuentra bajo la
supervisión del ministerio del interior
ucraniano sin embargo los altos mandos
del batallón creen que las respuestas
del gobierno son ineficaces para
enfrentar la amenaza de invasión
hoy en día estamos hablando del plan
preparado por la federación rusa para el
nuevo ataque contra territorios
ucranianos y al mismo tiempo estamos
hablando de la absoluta ineficiencia de
las acciones del gobierno y es por eso
que tomamos esta misión por nuestras
manos y comenzamos a entrenar a la
población civil los entrenamientos
consisten en instruir que van desde cómo
sostener un arma hasta maniobras más
complejas los alumnos son personas de
diversas edades y profesiones quiero
escuchar y ver para entender los
acontecimientos y obtener información de
primera mano para saber qué hacer en
caso de ataque en otro sitio de kiev la
capital ucraniana cientos de personas se
reunieron para agradecer el apoyo de
occidente en medio de las tensiones con
moscú
la multitud portaba pancartas elogiando
la otan banderas estadounidenses y de
otros miembros de la alianza
trasatlántica esto sucede mientras rusia
acumula unos 100.000 efectivos en la
frontera con ucrania